Why Toilet Paper is White
Toilet paper is an odd thing.
Despite the fact that we often rub it against
one of the most sensitive parts of our bodies
on a daily basis, very little thought is ever
given to where it came from or how it’s
made.
(On that note, it might surprise you to learn
that toilet paper wasn’t commonly used in
the United States until the early 20th century
and even later in many countries.)
You also, like us, may have found yourself
wondering why it is always white.
In the U.S., coloured toilet paper to match
one’s bathroom décor was all the rage in
the mid-20th century, with the popularity
peaking in the 1970s and then gradually waning
until today, when, outside of gag-shops, you’d
be hard-pressed to find a roll of coloured
toilet paper.
So why is this the case?
There are several reasons, but one of the
primary reasons toilet paper is white is the
same reason most toilets are, simply that
white toilet paper looks cleaner than the
natural brown-ish colour the paper is before
it’s bleached.
If toilet paper was the original brown hue,
on a purely aesthetic level, would you use
it?
Or, perhaps more aptly, would you prefer it
over the white variety?
The consensus among toilet paper makers, like
Kimberly-Clark who rang in on this issue,
is that people consistently choose the white.
One can only assume they’ve done extensive
marketing studies to back that notion up,
but even without access to those studies,
it makes intuitive sense.
That said, there are other factors at play
as well.
For starters, white isn’t just an aesthetic
choice, the white colour of toilet paper is
usually achieved by bleaching the paper and
this can make the paper much softer.
Why?
The bleaching process can be used to remove
lignin, a polymer in wood that to some extent
functions as a “glue” to hold the fibers
together and makes the tree more rigid.
As Dr. Hou-Min Chang of N.C.
State University in Raleigh said, “Without
lignin, a tree could only grow to about 6
ft. tall.”
Besides the added softness, removing lignin
also adds a significant amount of shelf-life
to the paper.
For example if you’ve ever seen an old newspaper,
you may notice that the paper starts to yellow
as it ages; this yellowing is due to the presence
of lignin in the newspaper.
Obviously toilet paper that yellows over time,
especially unevenly, isn’t going to fly
off the shelves.
So that’s partially why many toilet paper
manufacturers bleach the toilet paper in the
first place, but why don’t they still colour
it in many countries?
There are a variety of reasons ranging from
environmental impact of the dyes; potential
for irritating certain people’s skin, along
with other negative health factors; and increased
time of decomposition of the toilet paper,
which is particularly a problem when using
a septic system.
Of course, things like environmental impact
and potential health issues never stopped
them from bleaching the TP in the first place,
or adding many other chemicals to increase
desirable attributes of toilet paper, which
have many of the same drawbacks.
It also hasn’t stopped companies from adding
such dyes to other product if it will increase
sales, despite any negative impact.
So while those are definitely factors in favour
of leaving out the dyes, the primary reason
here probably has more to do with the extra
cost.
To make up for this, they’d need to charge
a little more for the dyed version.
If this would have the potential to increase
sales, they’d no doubt start making coloured
toilet paper tomorrow.
But as people today already generally prefer
the white, the extra expense probably isn’t
going to get customers to buy more, unless
they used some pretty clever marketing.
But even then for a product like this, it
would be a stretch unless it really was a
superior product compared to the white version.
So add it all up, and there’s not enough
incentive for the toilet paper makers to manufacture
such an alternative to the now standard white
variety.